aunque sabemos de carolina del norte con
el océano atlántico al este y la
cordillera de los apalaches al oeste
carolina del norte es un estado de
llanura
antiguo estado esclavista cuenta con un
poco más de 10 millones de habitantes
otra particularidad una fuerte comunidad
de cristianos evangélicos carolina del
norte es parte del cinturón bíblico el
punto fuerte del estado ha sido durante
mucho tiempo la agricultura en
particular el tabaco
hoy en día carolina del norte cuenta
también con alta tecnología alrededor
del triángulo de investigación de su
capital real y a nivel político el
estado voto demócrata hasta 1964 antes
de la adopción de la ley sobre los
derechos civiles desde entonces en su
mayoría se vota republicano es un
compendio de américa por un lado las
ciudades donde viven los estudiantes y
los moderados y por otro las campañas
blancas y conservadoras pero son sobre
todo los votantes afroamericanos los que
podrían marcar la diferencia pesan el
22% del electorado fue su movilización
lo que permitió a barack obama ganar el
estado y su abstención lo que le dio el
estado a donald trump
[Música]